投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,
現在是臺北時間2026年8月12號禮拜三,
早上8點31分,
大家早上維持又聽號,
每天早上開玩笑半小時,
我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經,
新聞時事變化。
美國股市在昨天美伊和平協議還是沒有顯著進展的情況底下,
市場上很明顯在等待接下來幾天的美國通膨數據出爐。
沒有股市昨天算是都普遍走黑了
不過下壓幅度也沒有特別大
反而晶片股在記憶體族群有逆勢走強
稍微收漲了0.8%
這一次在今天大家最為觀察的
就是輝達這一次所公佈
向華爾街籌資5000億美元的計劃
到底會不會是2008年GPU次代化
GPU證券化的可能性呢
那麼目前所面臨的挑戰
輝達推出的意義用意為何呢
明明他的現金流又這麼多
所以我們都清楚知道
AI的下一個階段
從以前我們都比誰的晶片最快
誰的生態系來得最為穩健
現在看起來是變成誰有足夠的錢
誰能夠把晶片
把電力
把資料中心全部蓋出來
這一次輝達宣佈和阿波羅黑石貝萊德
一系列的資產管理公司
六大金融集團合作
將會逐步動員5000億美元的第三方資金
來專門支援輝達生態系的AI基礎建設
你看以前上一年當時10月份
也差不多這個時間
AI永動機的高點
是由科技巨頭的互相投資
所達成的集體泡沫
這一次是把第三方給拉進來
由金融機構來專門籌資
背後原因是什麼呢
很明顯一年的時間
AI投資規模大到
科技公司自己快要吃不下了
根據摩根士坦利的推估
全球到2028年光是資料中心
建設大概就要2.9兆美元
其中1.4兆
大概是可以靠之前
大型雲端公司的自由現金流來支付
不過現在提前先花完了
所以馬上要開始進行資金缺口的填補
靠公司債
靠資產的證券化
靠之前的私募信貸
可是到現在還是不夠
所以一定要有一個集體性的聯合計劃
來跟金融業打交道
目前看起來
基本上可能會持續的把金額往上調高
在26年可能還要借到8700億美元左右
那這也是本輪的AI行情出現直變的地方
以前都是擔心晶片不夠
現在要擔心錢不夠
電不夠
以及誰來承擔這些債務
摩根士坦利的推估是
28年的電力需求會來到74幾瓦
那可以取得的電力缺口
可能已經高達49幾瓦了
所以不只是AI資料中心的需求
現在電力的需求
還有相關電廠的配置也越來越高
那更值得注意的事情是
輝達一方面是賣晶片
一方面是協助客戶取得資金
再由客戶拿這些資金購買輝達設備
那這種融資循環
就會讓營收成長和金融槓桿
它就綁得越來越緊
所以AI泡沫
現在你好像光是從本益比指標
也沒辦法直接看出來
因為它沒辦法反映這個表外的資產
那你要看什麼
你現在要改看現金流了
改看負債
敢看你的融資成本
那你發行投資等級債的利率是多少
難道你發行10年前20年期投資等級債
你給15%的利率
你都不擔心你有沒有能力付得起這麼高的利息嗎
這個是接下來市場上觀察的重點
那為什麼要找金融業
原因就來自於
如果你只單純發行投資等級債
或者消耗自由現金流
槓桿就會反映在自己的資產負債表身上
我們過去提過
這一次他找阿波羅找黑石
第三方基金成立SPV
就我們講的特殊目的公司
它的目的去蓋資料中心
再把算力租給雲端商
或者用專案融資私募信貸
目的是什麼
就是透過股權投資的方式
它可以在表外來進行認列
換句話說
這基本上你在揮達看到的賬面
因為客戶是把融來的錢
再拿去買GPU
你只會看到營收賬款
然後營收持續的增加
那真正增加的槓桿
都在其他人的財報裡頭
那這也不是財報造假
它只是單看輝達的負債比
可能會低估整條AI供應鏈的金融風險
所以現在變成
以前我們都要問
那個輝達到底欠人家多少錢
那現在要問的就是
那誰借錢買輝達的GPU
這筆錢資金鍊往外開始擴了
所以這是第一件事情
它其實並不會大幅度的
反映在輝達的資產負債表身上
那輝達為什麼還要這麼做呢
其實過去我們提過
第一個當然就是
輝達雖然本身現金流還是非常高
照來講
他也沒有那麼急著要做大規模融資
他靠自己的現金流就可以玩一陣子了
但是信用市場前陣子不信任他
我們看輝達在五年期的
信用違約交換的利差
當時是一路擴大到83個基點
即便整體投資等級在
企業利差其實表現相對穩定
相對於甲骨文
輝達算是很穩定
但是這也代表債券投資人
開始要求更高的風險補償
那市場上很明顯從CDS價格
我們可以把它理解成
公司倒債的保險費
就投資人持有輝達的債券
但是又擔心
你會不會以後還不出錢
那我就買你的CDS來避險
那利差越高
就代表這份保險越貴
舉例來說
現在五年期的CDS
已經來到83個基點
現在最高83
現在是重新回到79個基點
就大概可以理解成
1000萬美元的債務避險
一年的保費
大概要7.9萬美元
所以當然重點不是回答
CDS價格飆那麼快是不是要倒了
那不是這個問題
是你現在要去買它的債券
它的風險報價程度還要來得越高
那為了要緩解這個問題
我告訴你
反正風險不一定是全部由我承擔
銀行業自己也要承擔
那就成功地把風險轉嫁出去了
那看一下這一波CDS價格
是否能夠停止創高
那市場上很明顯
這一次找六大金融機構的目的
就是把輝達的單一風險往外開始擴
往整個金融體系來進行投放
那當然最後風險怎麼分配
我們會再做細節分析
可是華爾街現在正在把AI資料中心
當成一種可以融資
可以估值
可以轉手的資產
已經不是單純科技公司自己燒錢
燒不燒得下去
那這當然就把輝達單獨承擔損失的風險
大幅的壓低了
從去年AI10月份永動機以來的風險
然後從揮達資產負債表當中
轉移變成
變成債券投資人的風險了
變成私募基金的風險了
變成了保險基金的風險了
而且華爾街願意接受
但是這個條件
它也不是說完全安全的
像甲骨文就沒有達到這樣的一個態勢
即便甲骨文也跟金融業有所融資
可是甲骨文的CDS價格仍然在持續走高
當AI投資大量依靠債務和結構型融資
華爾街自己也不一定願意接受
但是華爾街現在願意接受
輝達的抵押品
那很多人會擔心
算力會不會反而變成
2008年的重演呢
我們把08年拿來類比
當然不是說GPU就等於房子
只是說它同樣都是把
實體資產未來的現金流
給它金融化
然後再借由金融的槓桿
把投資規模給放大
當年銀行是怎麼樣
一筆筆的把房貸
打包成MBS CDO
那投資人買的
其實未來十幾年的房貸的還款
你買的是這個產品
那今天的AI其實也差不多
就是你買GPU
然後蓋資料中心
籤長期的算力租約
然後再用未來的租金作為擔保
借到更多的錢
私募信貸
ABS等金融商品
再把這個風險再賣給你
賣給債券投資人
所以兩者的共同核心假設都是
反正資料中心以後就賺回來了
反正房貸到時候就還回來了
那未來的現金流會一直存在
08年就當時之前是相信房價不可能大跌
房貸總要還
房貸怎麼可能不還
那現在我們對於AI的投射一樣
AI總會賺錢的
它遲早會給你的
我們只是把未來會賺到的錢
提前打包成商品先賣給你
有這樣的一個感覺
那這件事情最大的意義
就是GPU以前都是三五年
就是折舊完的電子產品
現在變成產生長期現金流的基礎建設了
那隻要資金成本下滑
AI資料中心的投資報酬率
就會因此提高
接著帶動更多的GPU
電力 散熱 光通訊
或者相關的先進封裝需求
當然AI也一樣
最危險的都是金融模型
同時假設GPU的利用率永遠會很高
以後資料中心算力一定會很貴
所以你不用瞅
那最大的風險是什麼
因為算力突然變得很便宜
市場上不需要這麼多的算力
這才是最大的風險
所以這還是完全取決於
你認為我們10年以後
會大量的使用AI
到足以追上目前資料中心的建制速度
還是說你認為10年後
我們用到的AI
其實並沒有想象中來得多
最後會算力過剩
這是唯一的起見
當然了
其實你會發現
AI算力化
其實它就是等同於
資金效率化的一種翻版
跟大航海時代的金融創新很像
你想中世紀晚期
大航海時代是怎麼開始的
意大利 威尼斯
當時主要是靠海上貿易
主要是靠商船
海上貿易有很大的風險
你需要大規模投資
你一旦遇到風險就血本無歸
所以威尼斯人就發明了一種
叫集體投資風險分擔的公司形式
我們叫做康孟達
康孟達就是投資人提供資金
船主不出資
他只是返航之後
按照一定的比例來分紅
另外一種是海上合夥
他講的是投資人會提供主要資金
乘運人也出一部分資金
類似控股公司
那當時最有名的就是東印度公司
靠木奇至今成為有限公司的形式
具有法人的形式
股東大會是他的權力機構
他選了六十幾個董事
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
從威尼斯到荷蘭
東印度公司
一系列國家和公司的同構形態
他其實就是有人提供資金
效率化
那我們就勇敢的向前
現在的AI時代其實也差不多了
當然AI現在跟剛才提到的08年
有點像
跟當時的大航海時代
到底我們是迎來大航海時代
還是隻是一個
新一輪的次代化風險呢
這很難說
這還是取決於你的樂觀情緒
那我的態度
我就不用特別多說了
你知道我一直都是很樂觀的
但是呢
現在輝達出招了
用這樣的一個方式
讓整體資金動輪
把全球經濟
都拉到整條體系當中
科技決定人類能不能出海
金融呢
決定我們可以造多少船
那晶片的決定
應該講說晶片會決定AI未來能不能運算
那金融可以運算之後
最後我們能夠蓋幾座算力指標中心
這就是未來的挑戰
當然因為惠達現在體量也很大
所以當它這麼一做就代表著
其他企業我們相信很快就會因此跟上
大家開始陸續把自己的產品進行打包
交由華爾街來做售出
這也說明美股的AI集中化
會在未來幾家企業當中逐步呈現
因為你像輝達
現在平均每天的
明目成交金額
大概已經佔了
美國股市的3%
一家公司就吃掉了
全市場的三十分之一
甚至高於之前的美光
所以美光
你不要看記憶鐵骨炒這麼熱
它還是不如輝達的
總體成交量
另外一方面
輝達也要為未來的競爭
來做鋪路
因為現在全球市場
的確有點去GPU化的跡象
就是真正值得觀察
並不是AI需求降溫
AI需求完全沒降溫
是需求爆炸
但是增量從GPU轉向了自研晶片
自己研發
你像AI加速器現在的出貨量
去年是1010萬顆
今年是1630萬顆
明年是2330萬顆
可是GPU的佔比
從去年的68
反而現在下滑到47
預估未來可能會更低
說明雖然第一階段大家都在買灰打
可是規模夠大的公司
我們看幾隻科技巨頭
他已經自己開始造晶片了
當然這是增量市場
不代表輝達的出貨會衰退
可是你知道
這個餅漲得越快的過程當中
輝達的市佔率
好像沒辦法保持過去的高位
那這跟去年10月份的AI永動機
很多人說
那又有什麼樣的區別呢
你說現在有點累08年
資產正經化打包化
那去年10月份
難道不是如此嗎
去年10月份其實不太像
去年10月份
其實更類似於
AI公司彼此的互相抬轎
這一次是把華爾街
正式拉來接力
去年是大家彼此下單
然後彼此投資
資金鍊在整個AI生態系裡頭
持續的輪動
那之前是產業內循環
現在變成金融市場的加槓桿
以前那幾只巨頭在那邊玩
現在你的退休基金也進去了
保險資金也進去了
而且買的已經不單純是股市
刺激市場的股票
而是內加資料中心的抵押擔保品
就是把幾隻資料中心拿去抵押
換到錢再蓋下一座
那這資料中心
未來的分配的收益權
你就拿到了
這個是目前真實的跡象
爸爸先給兒子1000塊
再叫兒子回自己店裡消費
這是去年
現在是賬面上多了1000塊
但本質
去年還在自己的錢
自己的家裡頭鬧
或者說親戚朋友
資金在這邊輪動
現在是爸爸叫兒子
去銀行貸款100萬
然後再叫他拿這100萬
回店裡消費
爸爸的營收變得越來越大了
甚至還能夠繼續高成長
不過而此背上了真正的外部負債
這就是未來的一個問題
好那不管怎麼說
這就導致在這種借貸成本的
乘數效果底下
這一次AI的投資規模
我們應該幾乎可以確認
是史詩級規模最大
基本上已經逐步超越了
1836年到1841年的運河革命
當時是佔總GDP有0.6%
還超過了1870年的鐵路革命
1905年的電氣化革命
1956年的高速公路革命
還有1996年到03年的電信和光纖革命
所以我們現在的泡沫沒有比2000年來得大
可是我們的投資規模
看起來是遠遠比2000年還要來得高的
這是一個新的賽局
與此同時我們看到
由於現在半導體廠商
陸續進入到顯著的燒錢階段
Intel昨天也公佈
原本要規劃的150億美元的增資
一口氣直接擴大到200億美元
美股的發行價現在是95美元
比前日收盤大概折下2.6%
那這個時候大舉蒸發目的是什麼
它股價今年它已經翻三倍了
遠遠比肺瓣漲幅還要來得誇張
所以Intel相信市場正在相信轉型的故事
所以你當估值大幅回升之後
趁高股價的時候
Intel大概也知道現在股價它算偏高了
把樂觀情緒轉成現金
趕快拿來支付最燒錢的晶圓代工
還有先進封裝的擴張
那背後的壓力其實很清楚
就是資本支出
受到AI伺服器的需求帶動
Intel今年資本支出
已經從180億提高到200億美元了
而且2028年又要讓14A的製程
進入到大量生產
光是愛爾蘭晶圓的製造基地的升級
就要投入50億
佔今年資本支出的四分之一以上
所以現在我們看到
AI的軍備競賽都已經陸續開啟
過去我們看Intel的確落後臺積電非常多
可是在川普政府的實質幫助底下
今年的獲利是真的開始轉為翻增
而且股價有進一步的拉昇
剛才也講到了
當巨頭們紛紛開始持續砸錢
而且借錢瘋狂談條件的過程當中
雲端商的業務也開始營收暴漲了
Core Wave第二季的營收是25.8億美元
年增幅112%
這也非常漂亮
公司未完成訂單已經來到1040億美元
還沒有進入到本季的新增250億美元的承諾
所以其實整體業績上升幅度越來越快
我們做個總結
就輝達這一次找華爾街動員5000億美元
來搞這一次的AI基礎建設
裡面有很多東西值得長知識
包括SPV
包括私募信貸
資產的證券化
GPU的租賃
信用的增強
融資循環
你可以一路研究那個債務
現在到底是放在輝達
還是放在客戶
還是現在還主要集中在第三方的基金的資產負債表身上
這些金融工序當然要懂
我們要看清楚錢大概是往哪裡流
可是真正看懂的還是嘗試
不管融資結構包的多漂亮
最後就是你相不相信這些資料中心
未來能夠賺到錢
夠不夠支付利息
償還本金
這是你最原始的判斷
你相信就還得下去
你不相信
它就跟08年一樣始終是一場泡沫
如果資料中心利用率不如預期
AI服務賺不到足夠現金流
基本上估值就要被迫回調
但我們的相信
更類似於
我覺得現在算力很明顯不太夠
在算力過剩
跡象出現之前
似乎沒有什麼好擔心的
不過至少可以承認
就是說有時候知識可以讓你瞭解
當前的市況
大概的財經市場概況
但嘗試才是你決定
要不要持續參與本輪泡沫的原因
那之前最典型的福爾摩斯的故事
那福爾摩斯跟華生去露營
半夜華生就把福爾摩斯叫醒了
你看看天空
告訴我你看到了什麼
福爾摩斯看了很久
幾百萬顆的星星
華生問說
那你能夠推論出什麼呢
福爾摩斯就開始分析了
從天文學來看
代表宇宙有數百萬個星系
從氣象學來看
明天應該是晴天
從神學來看
人類真的是很渺小
華生聽完
靠杯我們的帳篷被偷了
所以知識會讓你看見宇宙
但常識會讓你發現帳篷被偷了
所以我們瞭解
現在有很多的知識
很多的訊息持續的交錯
讓大家覺得這場金融遊戲
好像越來越複雜
可是最後你要不要參與
你也不用管那麼多
那你相不相信
AI能夠達成生產力的提升
而且在未來幾年
你認為現在建制的算力中心
跟不上你的AI需求
這是最大的一個旗艦點
好我們看一下沒有股市四大指數表現
道瓊指數下跌184點
0.34%
是在53,791點
標普下跌24點
0.3%
是在7728點
納指下跌159點
0.6%
是在26,445點
費辦下跌104點
0.87%
是在12,098點
其實四大指數都還在高位進行盤旋
那反而是費辦
看這一次能不能一舉的直接回到
際線之上
現在市場上其實更為關注的
是美中之間的競爭態勢
它會如何影響到政府的
不管是國家政策的論調
來形成進一步泡沫的成長
因為現在是把第三方拉入進來了
所以泡沫可以撐得更大
如果你把國家隊整個扯進來
那麼國家的補助
國家的幫助
就會讓整個泡沫來得更加穩固
因為你知道背後有人在撐腰
黃仁勳當然最近是不斷提到
AI不能夠重演1980年代
封閉軟體的老路
他在之前第一篇的
這個Twitter
或者我們講在X平臺上
他就提到說
包括輝達
微軟
Parentier
Meta
IBM
這25家公司都呼籲
美國政府不要過早去限制
開放權重的AI模型
它的核心觀念很簡單
開放模型不只是讓新創大學
研究機構更容易使用AI
也能夠避免技術
被少數大型公司給壟斷
讓更多研究人員能夠檢查模型
所以他的目的是什麼
他的目的
當然他的口頭
當然是為了大學能夠研究
目的就是每個人都綁進AI
每個人都使用AI
當你作業從小到大
你要想想看
這一屆畢業的大學生
你看22年唸書
然後26年畢業
這一屆的畢業大學生
從寫論文寫作業
對跟女朋友對話
都是靠AI
他們是第一代完成
全AI教育的大學生
雖然課程可能沒交了
可是肯定用了很多AI
來應付一些作業
他們第一代出來以後
如果他們都無法去規避
避免使用AI
那麼就成功創造了新的世界
最後在AI需求不斷拉昇底下
黃仁勳的夢想就有可能成真了
當然了
祖克伯也發表了相關談話
他也認為
現在美國不應該禁止中國的AI模型
進入到美國市場當中
美國應該要找出
自身的技術發展瓶頸和障礙
不能只靠行政命令來打壓對手
這張圖片他長得好像班艾弗列克
他長得越來越帥了
重點是他認為現在針對AI的監管
祖克伯支持同業審查或者模型的測試製度
但是不能夠形成我們講的監管俘虜
或者說對於對方採取全面性的禁制令
因為目前我們需要把整個增量市場
把整條餅給做大
這個是目前幾家科技巨頭
針對AI開源模型的態度
它也引起現在華府跟科技業的持續紛爭
因為我們知道美國在本週已經正式宣佈
進一步擴大針對中國科技產品的限制範圍
美國聯邦通訊委員會宣佈
會把先進機器人到太陽能的逆變器
到部分吸金源
採取全面性的國家安全風險清單
這些措施它還沒有特別點中國
不過因為中國在全球機器人
還有逆變器市佔率上
它擁有壓倒性的優勢
普遍就是針對中國企業
祭出的新的限制
那北京政府這一次回應就很強硬
反對美國以國家安全為由
無條件的打壓中國企業
現在即將採取適度的報復措施
那事實上
美國這一次也會針對
中國資料中心的相關零組件
比如說光模組
採取新一波的進口禁制令
預估在本週週末
就會陸續的發佈
那普遍原因是因為
AI伺服器現在升級速度很快
那由於光模組
產品有分可插拔
低功耗的光學
或者共同封裝光學
還有細光一系列
客戶其實很難突然換供應商
所以他可能是發佈一個時間點
說在這之前
你必須找好下一家供應店
否則再過兩個月三個月
我們就要採取正式的禁止令
應該都不是直接性的替換
應該是讓美國企業
有能夠轉換的時間
但至少從這幾件事情看得出來
雙方的角力已經正在發展當中
你像中國最近對美國的科技限制
也開始展開訪集了
上禮拜五
中國商務部正式宣佈
把無人機關鍵零組件相關技術
直接採取出口管制
未來對於美國必須逐案審查
同時制裁六家美國企業
如果你們需要影印機
印表機
辦公設備
全部都要藉由中方的逐案通過
另外一方面
有任何無人機零組件的採購
直接管制
你想要非紅供應鏈
那我連紅都不願意給你
你想買什麼我也不願意給你
尤其在關鍵技術模組之類的
一系列所採用的衝擊
都會逐步的影響到美中之間的關係
因為我們知道美國商用無人機
在中國是有佔70%的市場
其實還是很大
這代表北京政府明明知道
現在擁有在市佔率上的優勢
還是在關鍵技術上採取逐岸審查
另外一個就是稀土供應鏈
這一次北京又逐步的收緊了
我們如果細看
過去一年當中一系列的稀土價格都在瘋狂的飆升
大概平均漲幅是7倍到8倍左右
這也導致美國歐盟日本正在投入數百億美元
來建立自己的關鍵礦業
這些都是我們看到實質的現況
那從這些數據其實都看得出來
這個中方一方面跟美方的脫鉤仍然在持續
另外一方面中方也缺錢
你要玩本場的AI遊戲
就一定要有人像輝達一樣繼續借錢
那這一次中國的IPO浪潮其實也來臨了
北京政府在本週正式宣佈
以前都是靠補貼低息貸款和國家資金
把28兆美元的股票和債券市場
當成AI產業政策工具
你們自己去股票市場上融資吧
會進行監管上的放鬆
讓你們儘量可以從散戶當中搶到錢
希望可以從民間超過26兆美元的家庭儲蓄當中
直接導向晶片人工智慧先進製造
以前買房的錢都不要買了
都先不買沒關係
房地產市場疲憊就讓他疲憊
重點趕快給這些企業IPO錢
長期存儲就是很明顯的例子
從申請上市到掛牌
連半年都不到
就已經募到了98億美元
股價還大漲
其他企業也是如此
今年中國大型科技公司的
發債平均票面利率
只有1.9%
但是融資規模是非常非常龐大的
一系列的融資需求
包括現在摩爾縣城
即將到香港來
來掛牌上市推動國際化
那第一波的上海
當時上市募資資金是81人民幣
價格漲幅也不錯
那現在看起來到港股掛牌以後
有沒有更進一步的拉昇
記憶體浪潮也是如此
從我們過去所提到的
像是紅星宇 江波龍
或者長興科技
長江存儲 武漢新興
東興半導體 新天下 大浦維電子
基本上陸續都在今年
下半年到明年年初會陸續掛牌
那最標準就語數
宇樹的IPO預估是每股價格150.8塊人民幣發行
4040萬股
預估會募集61億人民幣
現在中國是全產業鏈的
你要IPO
IPO速度就比你還快
反正現在中國股市表現也不錯
之前的Kimi K3 Moonshot
也準備要到香港掛牌了
估值上看500億美元
預估第一輪估值會做兩輪估值
一方面是在今年先做300億美元的估值募資
那另外一方面
在下半年到明年年初
應該就有機會
能夠成功的掛上港交所
這就是我們看到
中國公司推行的速度
其實越來越快了
所以必須承認
因為我們知道以前美國
針對整個中國市場的看法
一直都是比較兩極的
出發點都是對美國利益的最大化
對中鷹派的邏輯是什麼
就我領先
那你連我的妻子都不能拿到
所以進行全面性的
晶片科技設備的封鎖
那黃仁勳代表的是鴿派
他就是我領先
但是我應該讓全世界
尤其讓中國習慣使用我們的梯子
中國有工程師
有資本
有市場
你也很難阻止他發展AI
我們不賣
短期的確讓中國痛苦
可是我們反而讓他們
在華為
在深藤的中國生態軟體
他有一個被迫成長的保護區
不如我們現在把他的市場先拿下來
讓他被迫使用我的生態銷
即便他們自己有國家政策的補助
我們的產品這麼便宜
這麼好用
他們一樣
也很難取捨
最後被迫
可能還是要大量的
採用我們的生態系
所以從這兩點來看
雙方仍然在持續角力
可是真實的跡象是
現在中國政府似乎鐵了心
不管你到底要不要出口給我
我一定要趕快成立自己的供應鏈
美中科技站從原本的制裁
雙方都是確保自己不被斷供
所以即便在成本上
可能很多美系的客戶
美系的產品還是相對比較優質
我還是寧願選擇
我自己的供應鏈
這是中國政府自己強調的
所以有時候我們講說
美國以為不管是對中銀牌
還是比較鴿牌
能夠卡住中國晶片
其實最後中國的方向已經確認了
美國限制高階的AI晶片出口
很直覺就覺得
沒有先進GPU
中國算力就會不足
靠電力來補
人家是這樣想的
所以競爭最麻煩的地方
是你的限制本身
也可能會改變對手
你以為自己在削弱它
你有時候可能被迫
這幾年你是逼它再進化
這也是沒辦法的事情
之前看那讀者文哉
最經典的一篇故事
那一個男的到外地旅行
找點刺激
那計程車司機就跟他講
市中心有一間教堂
每天晚上12點
都有一個修女在裡面祈禱
你只要扮成耶穌
說你自己是主
他就會聽你做任何事情
男的真的照做
當天午夜就穿著耶穌的裝扮
走進教堂
你好 我是耶穌
主啊 我願意證明我的忠誠
男生就心想成功了
就結束之後
他就很得意的脫掉耶穌裝
哈哈你被騙了
我根本不是耶穌
那修女也把修女服脫掉
哈哈你也被騙了
我就是剛才那個計程車司機
所以有時候
你看美國以為自己扮成耶穌
騙到了中國
人家衣服一脫
你不給我晶片
我就被迫學會怎麼少用晶片
你都覺得好像雙方的動態
是對中鷹派或者對中鴿派
就會採取一個結果
沒有
沒有,
不管你怎麼做,
他已經想好了應變措施,
這是一個雙方博弈的過程,
而且是動態博弈,
你出一招我就出一招,
我們都知道不能夠直接撕破臉,
可是我們的長期利益的衝擊已經有了戰略核心,
這就是現在競爭有時候最好預測的地方,
但是也是最難預測的地方,
你的策略不只會傷害對手,
但是也會改造對手,
如果中國可以無條件的無限制的取得最先進的GPU
難道有這麼大的誘因
他會把每張晶片都用到極致
以後只買美國的供應鏈嗎
也不會
相反對於中國全面的鷹派
難道就會讓中國市場全面的崩潰嗎
也不會
他發展自己的供應鏈以後
有機會在第三方市場跟美系企業有的一拼
這就是真實的現象
也給投資朋友做些參考了
臺股小漲248點
時間原因稍微不太夠
我們今天主要是跟投資朋友稍微聊一下
一方面在本輪揮達的5000億美元的融資計劃
它本質上並不是一個像單純大眾的融資計劃
它是像華爾街來發明一個新的資產證券化產品
把資料中心進行新一輪抵押
所獲取的資金
那麼華爾街會把這些風險
逐步分攤到大量的散戶和債權人身上
第一個遊戲已經形成了
第二個遊戲是各大半導體廠和巨頭
看到這樣的一個模式形成以後
即便股價提升效果有限
大概也很願意採用這樣的一個模式
把本輪的AI遊戲持續的擴大
到時候你就不得不參與這樣的一個遊戲了
可是你最後還是要了解自己的初衷
你想不想要參與這場遊戲呢
你當然可以很努力的去研究本輪的債務遊戲
到底現在它有沒有反映在資財負債表身上
可是更重要的事情是
你的原則你相不相信AI會成功呢
正由於推達就是相信
我以後就會賺到錢了
那我現在錢有點不太夠
你先借我吧
有這樣的一個心態
那最後還是要了解自己的初衷
你認為AI生產力能不能有效提升
你是不是一個科技樂觀論者呢
這是最大的區別
當然回過頭說
科技巨頭對於美國政府的影響也越來越大了
那這些鴿派都希望能夠搶佔中國市場
但是對他們來講說
你要想看那球員兼懲判
你就是賣鏟子的人
所以你好像也沒辦法直接定力計劃
那到底白宮最後的態度為何呢
我們稍晚再來做一些追蹤
可是你也清楚知道
白宮對中鷹派的政策
效果是越來越薄弱了
市場上很明顯知道
不管你對他鷹還是對他哥
都沒辦法大幅的改變
目前中國政府的實質立場
給投資朋友多做一些觀察
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上半夜半
早晨財經速寫讀
再相見
祝各位投資朋友
開盤順利
操盤愉快